un golpe a la extrema derecha de
alemania los servicios de inteligencia
están formalmente monitoreando al
partido a efe por tener presuntos
vínculos con el extremismo en el
contexto de nuestra experiencia en la
historia de alemania puedo comprender
plenamente que la oficina para la
protección de la constitución haya
designado a alternatiba para alemania
como un caso sospechoso de extremismo de
derecha se permitirá que los agentes de
inteligencia vigilen al partido escuchen
sus llamadas y utilicen informantes
encubiertos la medida llega tras una
investigación de dos años las pruebas
fueron publicadas en un informe que
incluye discursos y declaraciones de
miembros del partido se espera que esté
proporciona evidencia de que la afe de
socava los valores democráticos
alternativo para alemania ha empleado
una retórica abiertamente anti islámica
y antisistema también están bajo
escrutinio en los miembros del partido
afiliados a una facción radical pero
ahora disuelta de la afe de el partido
anti-inmigración fue impulsada al
parlamento durante las elecciones
federales de alemania de 2017 cuatro
años después
convertido en el principal partido de
oposición en el bundestag las últimas
encuestas muestran que su popularidad
está entre el 9 y el 11 por ciento la
fed dice que está siendo atacada en un
intento por dañar las posibilidades
electorales del partido
si vemos esto como un escándalo
claramente esto fue motivado
políticamente especialmente en vista de
las dos próximas elecciones estatales y
las elecciones federales
la ministra actual los legisladores de a
efe de elegidos en el ámbito nacional
los parlamentos regionales o europeos
quedarían excluidos del seguimiento